[Music]
did you ever think you were made
Sweet Victory I know this life meant for
me yeah why would you bet on Goliath
when we got fat David now you came in
giving values contagious
homie look what I become
[Music]
okay so this is an emergency podcast for
obvious reasons everybody is texting
calling did you hear the news did you
see what happened Tucker Carlson no
longer with Fox Don Lemon moments later
fired both respond not Tucker hasn't
responded yet but Don Lemon has here's
what fox says says we thank him for his
service to the network as a host and
prior to that as a contributor Mr
Carlson's last program was aired Friday
21st CNN about Don Lemon says CNN and
Don have parted ways Don will forever be
part of the CNN family and we thank him
for his contributions over the last 17
years we wish him well and we will be
cheering him on in his future endeavors
but this is what Don said slightly
different I was informed this morning by
my agent that I've been terminated by
CNN I am stunned after 17 years at CNN I
would have thought that someone in
management would have had the decency to
tell me directly at note time was I ever
given any indication that would not be
able to continue to do work I have loved
at the network FYI Fox's stock is down
CNN stocks up which tells you CNN
shareholders are Happy Lemon is no
longer with them Fox shareholders are
disappointed that Tucker is no longer
with them there's a lot of different
stories circulating we'll talk about it
what was your immediate reaction when
you heard the news well the Tucker thing
was whoa breaking news yeah like that
came out of absolute nowhere all right
and people are texting what do you think
about this whereas he's going clearly
Tucker has way more leverage and way
more options than Don Lemon when the Don
Lemon thing happened and he was Shell
Shocked I mean I think it was the
writing was on the wall for Don Lemon
for well over a year now he's been a
dead man walking at CNN ever since Chris
lick the new CEO took over for Jeff
Zucker
um his show which I think believe I
believe was used to be at 8pm 9 p.m
right after Anderson Cooper those guys
right after Cuomo those two had a little
Bromance going on he got demoted to the
morning show which their ratings of our
bottom of the Morning ratings compared
to Fox and Friends and compared to uh
MSN MSNBC Morning Joe but then he was
had a leave of absence so as far as Don
Lemon goes he's either completely naive
or just completely living in a fantasy
land the fact that he didn't see the
writing on the wall everybody saw the
writing on the wall for you Don Lemon no
but but I I think Pat that well Don
Lemon bro he's mind you he's hardcore
left he pushes their agenda he thought
he was Untouchable because how many
sexual assault allegedly a sexual
assault he assaulted waiters in New York
he's he's saying the stuff he says about
women he thought he was Untouchable this
is this is I think you're wrong I think
it's a real shock because he's like wait
a minute I'm I check all the boxes he's
a gay dude he's a black guy they can't
fire me and he got shocked but the
Tucker thing if you think about it
Tucker was Fox News I don't care why
everybody else to me Pat that is a
filler Don bongino I love all that but
dude Tucker is Tucker the team the
writing the producing the the topics the
the ballsiness he doesn't care he spits
the truth I think he's obviously way
more uh important and necessary and I'm
just I mean shocked I had a cousin that
I haven't talked to in years Pat that's
the first text I've gotten in years was
did you see what happened that's that's
the one that I got but it's gonna be a
very interesting 24 hours
I I think the Don Lemon statement that
was on Twitter I found um really
disappointing uh because I think I've
listened to his reporting
um I've certain reports that he's done
I've really liked him over the years I
thought he did an incredibly honest one
several years ago about um
African-American men and the
African-American family that I thought
was very honest very direct I think good
piece of Journalism there and I was just
very disappointed to read this because
this this red is bitter
um at no time was I given any indication
wait a minute you were you were demoted
to the morning as Adam just said you
were put on basically probation a leave
of absence to go think it out did we get
Tom some icon or no people are saying
this mic check for Tom
can can Tom say something
no we can't hear us I'll come back to
you so but you know go ahead no I was
going to say I think as far as Don Lemon
goes while we're on that yeah Vinnie hit
the nail on the head as far as you know
hitting checking all the boxes you know
everything that happens with the Dei
movement diversity Equity inclusion you
got a gay black guy who's gonna
basically sing lock and step with your
agenda you would think on the surface
Don Lemon is the poster boy for what CNN
would want to do but
let's talk about this let's talk about
this so uh there's there's Rob did you
say another story just came in from
mediaite or somewhere else about uh uh
if you want to read that what you just
saw right now correct uh it was a firing
uh Tucker Carlson's exit from Fox was
not voluntary according to sources that
spoke with mediaite uh Tucker Carlson's
departure from Fox News was not
voluntary multiple sources have told
mediaite Fox News shocked the world uh
the media World Monday morning with the
statement announcing the network and its
top rated hosts have agreed to parted
ways uh down here uh Carlson's final
show that aired Friday night showed no
indication he expected it to be his last
with the host signing off by telling his
audience we'll be back on Monday a
source who spoke with mediaite on
condition of anonymity revealed that
Carlson was in fact shocked by the news
according to the source he was totally
surprised he had no idea another source
added it was a firing Carlson was
informed today explaining why it closed
Friday's show saying hey be back on
Monday so let me ask you a question Pat
we we just covered the Dominion lawsuit
785 million that just came down the pike
what Thursday Friday whenever we
discussed that
how much is this firing of Tucker
Carlson in your opinion a byproduct of
that
well did you see what he what his last
episode was about no you didn't see what
his last episode was about so his last
episode uh Jorge you guys got to tell me
what you're doing so I'm watching for
you and I'm hearing you screaming and I
I don't know what you guys are doing
with the mic give me a signal yes thank
you so you know on Friday he did his
last episode and he talked about RFK he
said imagine if uh I work for a company
and imagine if Fox News was being fed
and were promoting these pillow guys and
behind closed doors and we keep saying
this and whatever they tell us to do we
silence ourselves and we don't say
anything that would never happen on Fox
news right that that's what his message
was about on Friday wow okay and he was
talking about RFK he was talking about
calling out the fact that other media
platforms you know because of big Pharma
they can tell you to Silence Yourself
all this stuff now
what's he talking about Fox the question
is did he know anything on Friday did he
know anything on Thursday did he know
anything last week has he felt anything
at Fox that now that Rupert Murdoch who
is I I want to say he's 92 years old I
don't know how old he is he's getting up
there yeah I recently engaged and that
called it off he's 92 years old March
11th he turned 92 and in the media
industry this guy's one of the biggest
heavyweights you know owns Wall Street
Journal owns New York Post owns Fox that
pretty much had the entire you know
Conservative Republican right-wing side
he's had a monopoly on for years however
he does have two boys
and his two sons I believe he's got two
boys that are running the company and uh
what's the other one is it James James
yeah two of these guys that are running
the company and politically they're not
fully on the same page as their father
is oh wow and they're not wanting to go
necessarily in the same direction as
pops now we don't know that for a fact
these are all a lot of speculation that
people talk about but there's two
there's a couple things that's going on
here what do you think about when you're
92 how many people at 92 are still doing
deals and you know running and gunning
are you thinking about that now Kirk
accordion he was still doing deals and
Warren Buffett John Wooden he's still
doing deals you know Buffett some of
these guys yes you would put them up
there Charlie's now this 100. he's
charges now 100 yeah so is it close to
100 very very close yeah it's like 98.
so so there's also an element of I
worked at a company Valley Total Fitness
in the 80s that was the gym everybody
would wanted to go to Bally's they were
sales guys in the 80s at Bally's making
150 Grand a year in the 80s 150 was a
lot of money of course because you would
sell contracts so people were happy
everybody wanted to work at Bally's they
had the best training great things was
going on and then all of a sudden boom
suddenly things changed standards
changed comp change Vision change it was
no longer about being the best in the
marketplace anymore then what happened
gradually one guy second guy left third
guy left fourth guy left and it was an
exodus with Bally's and the rest is
history so today you know with Fox they
may be sitting there saying well you
know you have to be very careful what's
going on after dominion 787 that's 20 of
your savings in your bank account from
four billion dollars that's not a little
bit of money it's a lot of money that
goes and gets depleted over a lawsuit
that's a settlement so by the way none
of the lawsuit was any of it tied to
Tucker it was other hosts it wasn't
Tucker 100 it wasn't even CNN talked
about it just an hour ago okay on CNN 35
45 minutes ago
the CNN host said that 787 had nothing
to do with Tucker Carlson it was other
hosts right this isn't fox saying it
this is an MSNBC saying it this is Siena
saying it okay so so about what
is this just pop together so so Paul
would you so would you so 100 that's
what they're saying has nothing to do
with it but do you think in a settlement
like that where they go listen Maybe
Dominion the lawyers are like listen
we're going to settle we won't take this
anywhere further but Tucker got to go
you think that's something I think what
do you think maybe Dominion's like okay
listen we'll we'll fight this past for
billions let me tell you but give us let
me tell you something have you heard
rumors that Tucker is not a good
teammate not at all okay so let me ask
the question maybe in a different way
God let's talk about certain players did
you hear about Antonio Brown not being a
good teammate
have we heard Terrell Owens being a good
teammate
[Laughter]
you're laughing about it right okay we
heard about who else can you say in
different sports being good teammates
give me give me players it doesn't
matter I don't care any sports Tom Brady
Tom Brady's always been a good teammate
okay Gronkowski good teammate okay have
have you heard stories about it's hard
to play with Kobe because Kobe would
drive people to being so tired mentally
mess with them yeah yeah we've heard
about that so we can't fake that that's
a real story right okay what have you
heard about Tucker as a teammate nothing
negative zero he's number one period
kicking everyone's tail Tucker's not
duplicatable you can't find another
Tucker okay a lot of people think
they're Tuckers then there's Tucker a
lot of people think they're rogans then
there's Rogan you cannot do applicator
Tucker so for Fox News to choose to do
this over the pressures coming from the
outside if you do there could be
something that we don't even know that's
all I was going to say okay something
that none of us even know where the
reason was behind it and here's what
we're doing
um anyways that's one of the things that
you're hearing about go ahead I fully
agree that Tucker is not duplicatable
but
you know this whole question of loyalty
that Trump always brings up well
DeSantis wasn't loyal to me loyalty
loyalty loyalty I don't know how loyal
Tucker was to Fox keep in mind
he's been on CNN before Crossfire with
Alan Combs or whatever his name was uh
he's been on MSNBC Tucker's not a Roger
Ailes groomed product of fox he's been
around the block talented no doubt been
all over Washington I don't know how
much loyalty Tucker has
to Fox and then if you go down the the
rabbit hole of who's really been the the
top dogs at Fox
I feel like Fox believes their brand is
bigger than one particular person just a
handful of years ago it was all about
Megan Kelly yeah then she took her ball
and left to uh took her talents to NBC I
believe her ABC she's no longer there
anymore she's building her own
podcast she's crushing it Bill O'Reilly
Bill O'Reilly was the number one guy on
Fox 20 years yeah he was the guy yeah he
wasn't Tucker so if you look at the the
ratings now the most watched show on Fox
these days is not Tucker as far as the
five yeah so you got the five number one
at 3.3 million viewers a week you got
Tucker you've got Jesse Waters secretly
uh number three you would think that
it's Hannity Hannity's number four and
then you got Brett Bear number five
by the way Fox News 92 out of the 100
highest rated cable shows are on Fox
News that's crazy so their bench is
crazy and then you talk about the late
night TV shows
Greg gutfels the number one late night
show on all of TV not Colbert not Fallon
not Kimmel so fox has built up a bench
we talk about how deep is your bench the
Democratic party doesn't have a deep
bench
I don't know what's going on I don't
know what transpires but something tells
me fox says they they believe they are
bigger than any one individual including
Tucker and Pat Rob said this Judo is on
the way here uh this might say a lot
Tucker Carlson senior executive producer
the number one guy Justin Wells follow
Tucker and left Fox I didn't say he got
fired that either that means he's a ride
or die panels like listen wherever the
star goals I'm going because a good EP
you know that good executive producer
with those writers take me anywhere just
put a camera they can do it so I'm
interested to see if that guy got fired
because now we're finding out the Tucker
apparently got fired but that's the guy
let's see if Tom is still being silenced
go ahead Tom
no I I agree with what you were just
saying and I'll add to it you know one
person is not bigger than the brand
um and when you take a look at the
people that have left fox fox has done
just fine you know really what you have
there is you have the time slot that
Tucker was in and Tucker worked for the
audience that's coming for that time
slot and I believe Jesse Waters I'm not
going to call it but I'm I really look
at the lineup and I say I think Jesse
Waters is such an easy slot in and then
he'll be the 3.5 million guy because
remember the audience is coming for the
time slot and then the the host that
takes it over adds to it now then that's
Fox but what you have to remember Tucker
Carlson is a phenomenal Talent this is
the guy that built a digital media
company this is the guy that has built a
career so anybody that thinks well we'll
just get another wide receiver that's
not true either so is the fox brand
significant are they going to be able to
put somebody in the slot yeah but this
guy is a generational Talent this is a
tremendous guy I don't
I don't necessarily agree with you that
they're just going to be able to
slot in Jesse Waters to fill in for
Tucker I feel like Tucker's an A-Plus
talent and Jesse is maybe a B I don't
know but I think don't forget Jesse
Waters used to do water like man on the
street Waters world for Bill O'Reilly
yeah he was his sidekick so I I I think
who's the next person to roll I could
see uh
Sean Hannity just well I'm out of there
in no time but and Adam then I'm coming
from Hollywood I'm telling you guys the
writers on that show made that show yes
I mean Tucker obviously it's the voice
it's the delivery it's in but I'm
curious to see if those same writers are
gonna stick with Fox and write for the
person that's going to step into that
spot or they're gonna go with Tucker
with the executive producer okay that's
a big question so a few different things
that's been coming up with this
situation here with Tucker is you know
does this guy really want want to run
for office is this a type of guy that
could run for office and be a president
is is he that guy or does he just want
to do media for the rest of his life if
he did would he have a chance a lot of
people want him to run should he run
should he not run should he sit on the
sidelines is this a good time to get
involved to get in because if you if you
think about how Tucker is Tucker is not
team Trump and Tucker is not team
DeSantis Tucker is team audience wow
talker Tucker talks to his audience
Tucker doesn't ever go you know know
lock you know he he's the there's a
reason why even the left listens to
Tucker yeah people who are liberals
listen to Tucker they may not like the
guy but they listen to the guy right
they may not agree with what he has to
say but they'll say this guy is the guy
that I gotta listen to to see what the
other side's thinking about this is a
you know every once in a while you know
you think about it and you say well you
know forever we're going to be fine
because we're a larger organization
we're bigger than this yes uh the
Yankees are they bigger than a player
yes of course they are yeah 27 World
Series Championships you are
Lakers are they bigger than a player yes
10 championships in 32 years of you know
Jerry bus owning the team they've won 17
championships tied with the Celtics you
know when Shaq said I'm gonna go get 20
million a year what did he say he says
go get Johnny I can't pay you that Jerry
bus banked on who Kobe right okay are
the Bulls bigger than a Player No nope
they've never won no since Michael yeah
okay so so you know there are certain
Pittsburgh Steelers are going to win you
know hey Patriots bigger than Tom Brady
ah no Brady left you kind of are not
winning anything right whether you had
the new quarterback or the other
quarterback or who they have right now
Max Jones or Matt Jones
the other guy that was there who was uh
with the not Auburn he played for Auburn
Cam Newton was there for like a split
second two seasons
so look obviously none of us know Dan
bongino is no longer with Fox that's
last week
the 20th Dan bongino Fox News show ends
abruptly after contract talks breakdown
okay so that's Dan bongino all right
well can I can I win quick Tucker story
because it kind of proves your point
about caring what the audience has to
say I was fortunate enough to be at a
insurance meeting the ALU and DC you
know it's there every year how we met at
one of these types of meetings and they
had a panel with Tucker Carlson
obviously it was a Republican strategist
at that time and Paul bagala huge
Democratic strategist and an opportunity
to do a little happy hour uh after the
event with Tucker and I happened to just
be standing right next to Tucker and I
go Tucker quick question for you what
happened to your old look with the bow
tie right and it goes oh you want to
know he goes everyone told me I looked
like a douchebag so I just I said
enough's enough with the uh with the bow
tie yeah that was that's what John
Taylor remember John Daley talking so
that was his look so it's taking cues
from the audience I mean that was his
look back in the day if you're if you're
not uh old enough to remember young
Tucker
um but that that was his look but I
think now with the bongino thing with
Tucker uh with Don Lemon
a bigger question that we talk about is
disruption right there's disruption with
Bitcoin disrupting the financial markets
with politics with Trump's disruption
with YouTube and Spotify and podcasting
disrupting mainstream Legacy Media is
the writing on the wall for someone like
Tucker saying I don't need this
mainstream media [__] corporate cow
Towing to these types of corporate
sponsorships and basically hand tying
what I can say I can go do what Megan
Kelly's been doing I can do what pbd's
been doing I can do what Rogan's been
doing I can do what Russell Brand's been
doing I could do to him my own [__]
bring my own audience with me and make
my own money how much of that do you
think is factoring into this situation I
I don't think that's that's uh uh I look
he's the kind of guy so let's let's kind
of talk about people that can make it in
different places yeah can you see Tucker
competing on the political stage
debating others I can see that yeah yeah
can you see Tucker having his own
podcast and doing well no question about
it can you see Tucker on cable TV doing
it and killing it no question about it
uh can can you see Tucker running his
own small business and growing a Daily
Caller no question about it
this is this is a multi-faceted talented
guy and uh I think he's a May baby May
16th or May 13th he is 53 years old
about to be 54. I think out of all of
them and Dan bongino's the youngest he's
49 years old or 48 years old and Don
Lemon is the oldest he's 57 years old if
I'm not mistaken yeah Don Lemon is the
oldest he looks like he's 35 by the way
shout out to him for black showing crap
baby yeah yeah he's a good looking guy
so so look at the different platforms
okay because you know a guy like this
when he's a free agent who's calling him
everybody's calling us everybody who do
you think he would fit well with and who
do you think he would entertain going to
I think valuetainment like no and I'm
being genuine this is the ideal place
for somebody like that to be Pat because
I mean yeah it's going to be on YouTube
obviously but you're free you can say
what you want there's nothing that I
think I mean everything that he said so
far because I watch them it's nothing's
like too crazy he just says it like you
said you know why he's never said I'd
vote for Trump or I'd vote for DeSantis
he's right in the middle and he lets the
facts like go where they may that's it
it's the truth is the truth and if it
hurts it hurts and he doesn't give a
damn so I mean they're obviously a
rumble would would easily take him
so I I think there's a massive
disruption going on right now first of
all I I think he he would fit here he
would definitely fit here because of the
number one the journalists of Freedom
you could expand number two this is
where the audience is going I was
reading articles over the week uh I read
in semaphore and in Vox and they were
talking about the massive disruption
that's going on here it's like
Huffington Post is very quietly trying
to get back to subscription and trying
to get back to a prophet Vice media has
been trying to sell itself for three
years BuzzFeed just laid off a huge
chunk of it so all of the playing field
that was in New Media there is a
cataclysmic change going on because the
companies that are purveying it are
coming out and the flat home page with
subscription accompanying a traditional
cable channel with the exception of fox
it's hard to make money out there it's
very hard to make money out there a
certain South African billionaire has
made money trying to make money on a um
a text platform laid off 80 of the
people and said if you're going to
operate a text platform at scale to the
way to make money it you don't need a
large group of people to do it you might
just hit the nail on the head
because Tucker just interviewed
Elon yes recently how long ago was that
a week a week ago two weeks ago and
that's exactly the the point that he was
kind of trying to establish is that he's
laid off 80 of what he called like
activists Workforce yeah how much of a
conversation are Elon and Tucker having
these days Twitter platform they're
trying to create the super super app
right what is it called and so I don't
know how much of that could be factored
into this you know elon's in the media
game now if he's in Twitter
I don't know I I don't I don't know
about that it may because if Elon was
going to get anybody Elon would probably
get Rogan first before he goes after
Tucker because that's more of his cup of
tea than it is Tucker you you don't
really see but again you never know
could there be a conversation
uh uh Offline that hey what do you want
to do I'll invest in what do you want
whatever you want to do hey I'm doing
Xbox yeah I put 20 billion I put 50
million I put 100 million I'll give you
some money invest into your company that
that kind of a conversation I fully see
it
um I fully see it yeah okay so look look
at names like him the comparison some
people are making is at Fox you got him
you got a Riley you got back okay Beck
went and did what the blaze O'Reilly did
what he just kind of yeah
what did he do O'Reilly did you have to
remember what he did he went to an
independent personal platform with
Dennis Miller they've been on tour for
five years selling out and he's not just
promoting books There Is A Commentary
that he and Dennis Miller do and so
Riley said my platform is going to be
auditoriums Across America and I'm gonna
go door-to-door to do it that's what he
did he didn't turn around he didn't
crawl in a hole and die how old is Bill
O'Reilly now 80s 114. 800 guys he's
probably he's probably 68 or 70 years
old
yeah I don't know how much of this this
is me just but what Elon talks about you
shouldn't have sent it inarians in
politics anymore anyone 70 plus
Bill O'Reilly 73 Trump 78 you saw the
new numbers that came out even from the
Democratic party Biden you know how they
do like that word spreadsheet totally
it's just like old senile too old it's
just like
I think Tucker would we say 53
I think he you know he's having
conversations with Musk and the writing
on the wall for mainstream media is like
it's a Dying Breed I mean what's the
average age of a fox viewer dead 70
something so it's like if you want to
get yourself in with the millennial
crowd the 30 40 50 plus crowd is Fox the
future I doubt it it's CNN even the
future doubt that as well this is the
future I was I was just gonna say I know
we talked about the last podcast when we
went to a go watch as a as a unit we
went to go watch the movie air with my
you know the whole story of Nike and the
this is a perfect opportunity for a
company like this Pat and I hope that
he's listening to come and give that
person a chance that's like you know
what we're young we're hot we're blue
we're ready and we look and we see that
we have the same vision of where the
country should be where the country's
going and what mistakes we should or we
should not make to keep this staying
America that it is because it looks like
it's going down the tubes pretty damn
fast Tom I I think there's a new NATO
out there and it's the people that want
to stay right in the middle slightly
conservative and have objective debates
and conversations about these and that's
where we sit and I'm and you know what
anybody that wants to say oh you're just
singing your own song Tom you you put it
in Super Chat and complain about me if
you will but I think objectively if you
look the way we covered things the
opportunity and the microphone that we
give to people it's not just on our side
it's there's an objective Center and I
think there's a new NATO out there of
folks like Joe Rogan that are very
similar to us and the audience that is
being attracted is showing America that
those are the new organizations that
they want to give their patronage to and
I think that's where it's at so um to
your point about Twitter I don't think
he's talking to Elon because Elon is
building a highly democratized open
platform for everybody and as soon as
you were to retain even one Talent even
if it was a mascot you you're you're
kind of making a bet on one side or the
other because everybody's honest on us
Square on the chessboard no one's dead
center and so I I don't think he would
do that I think Elon just wants to let
the uh the democratized platform be an
uninhibited Fair democratized platform
obviously you're having fun you're
seeing him coming here we're having fun
about this that's not something Tucker
Tucker is going to be able to do what
Tucker wants to do but for me I'm
thinking about it from a different
standpoint so at think about your when
you were 16 years old what did you think
about
what was priority at 16. you don't want
to know what I was thinking
playing sports video games stuff like
that nothing entrepreneurship
I want to have fun with my buds and
figure out what I was doing for college
because it was coming up in two years
okay you were responsible not me what
how about 26 what were you thinking
about 26 different than 16.
there's a part of this that kind of
sucks yeah okay what else are you
thinking about 26 because this was out
for the military about I was thinking
more of like okay what do I want to do
for the rest of my life where am I at
yeah do I want a family do it like I
it's it's like you're you're figuring it
out 26. 16 I went from being a uh just a
jack of all trades to actually having a
profession and being a specialist and
starting to actually make money up until
I was 25 26 money wasn't a major concern
but I think something you know a light
bulb goes off after a certain age 25 was
from okay how about 36
36 now you're talking 36 is crunch time
settling down marriage kids career
you've made your money maybe now what do
you want to do how do you want to pursue
what type of passions none of you had a
kid at 36. no
no you got three different looking
Playboys here
no 36 house the two-time uncle and I was
trying to really be a good uncle I was
really worried about being a really good
uncle on the time what were you doing at
36 36 I was running venture capital for
Sprint okay so we can't go 46 but think
about
54. okay so you're 53 years old okay
your number one in your space got you
you're not a top ten you're not a top
five you are it yes and I know the five
is the five but this is one name yeah
when you think one name you think Tucker
no doubt you don't think any other name
but Tucker yeah what Tucker it was Joe
Rogan is for podcasts and Tucker is for
cable TV I agree period right okay so at
this point you've made money
uh uh you have a lot of haters you have
a lot of fans you have a lot of True
Believers you know what you want and
what you don't want you're living a life
where you know the way you're doing
everything your podcast your show you
get to dictate your terms and you're
seeing what's going on in politics today
and and and this is the part this is the
part you have to be thinking about I've
seen this happen different types of
things for different people there's one
group that you see people at that age
that they've been disappointed and hurt
so many times that they trust fewer and
fewer and fewer and fewer and fewer
people in their life and you almost
become cold and what I mean by cold is I
mean literally
you become cold nothing is attractive
when somebody says something to you
because all you think about is that's
also what they said to me yeah that's
also what that guy said to me and that's
also what this person said to me
[__] you're just like the other
person but it sounds good it sounds
convincing so you're more
you're harder to convince you're harder
to crack you're harder to persuade you
know the typical things that maybe got
you excited hey we're gonna pay you two
and a half million dollars a year for
five years they're like
what can't I buy with the current life
that I have everything but I do think to
some people when this happens you sit
there and you ask yourself I'm really
concerned about what's going on with
America I'm really concerned with what's
going on with certain things during
cobit a lot of stuff was exposed you
either become such a deep True Believer
that your fight is not for real reason
you're a parent you have all these other
things that's going on with you I think
Tucker's a True Believer today and
there's a part of him that he's sitting
there saying I give all this stuff to
Fox for all these years I give you the
number one show I'm not number two I'm
not number four I'm not number eight you
know what it takes to be number one let
me tell you what it takes to be number
one you have to read every story you
have to read every book you have to
follow what everybody else is doing you
have to study history books you have to
go do hours on top of hours on Saturday
while everybody's kicking it golfing
you're reading articles on Sunday
morning while everybody is kicking it
relaxing sleeping in your reading
articles the number one of any space
does things that number two dozen two or
three or five even dreams about this is
a guy that's willing to do the work
willing to put in the legwork is smart
it's intelligent is funny it's sarcastic
and is still young at 53. and you're now
sitting there saying what do I do next
well if if he's a crusade guy and he
loves America as much as he shows that
he loves America I think the next phase
maybe uh he has one or two choices do I
chase the billions
do I go make a few hundred million
dollars because he hasn't made a few
hundred million dollars yet he hasn't
made that kind of money before do I go
after that or do I kind of step up right
now run for office or do I go somewhere
what do I do or all these people that
have had to answer to maybe I'm gonna do
my own thing today and I want to build
my own Fox I want to build my own sin
these are the things that he's thinking
about himself but he can go any of those
directions and he'll succeed but you
better believe a guy that's going to be
pitching him today it's not going to be
the pitch from the movie Air it's going
to be a very different pitch really
you're pitching to a 19 year old oh yeah
good boy so the parents of the night
those parents I've never seen money
before yeah those parents have never
gotten real money before they still live
in the same house that they've lived in
for five generations the Jordan family
this guy's seen money before this guy
I've seen everything before and he also
knows he's the best of the best of the
best today so how long will that last
what am I going to do with it those are
some of the things he's thinking about
Tom I I agree with that because it's
it's like this is now a chapter
that
um I kind of I kind of see it as
you know there are certain proxies that
you see every now and then in
professional sports
um Brady went to Tampa and was
successful
um by the way I I think Tucker's got a
lot more than three seasons left in his
bag yeah of course babies I think he's
got 20.
I think Tucker realistically has 15 to
20 Seasons left Peyton Manning Went to
went to Denver and was the last piece
that they need but he did it on his
terms and he had three fantastic seasons
and I think Tucker's got that kind of an
opportunity this I believe in many ways
they may have done him a favor you know
why because everything I was reading
this weekend media is changing it is
changing and in many ways I think he has
been given a tremendous opportunity at a
time where all these media Outlets are
are struggling and you everybody you
have to remember BuzzFeed at one point I
believe was worth 1.6 billion dollars
today it's valued at slightly less than
100 million that's crazy and they're on
the market right now yeah that's it's 82
million dollars today 81.69 by the way
speaking of of money because how much
money is going to be a factor for Tucker
because I'm looking at the highest paid
cable news talk show host you know
number one is it's not even close Sean
Hannity number one I think he makes 45
million dollars a Year's net worth 250
million according to Yahoo news there's
a lot of Yahoo uh articles out there I
mean that sarcastically but what you
can't really
uh trust everything you see online but
you know we'll go with Yahoo on this
number two Anderson Cooper makes 12
million bucks a year number three Laura
Ingram she makes 15 a year shirt net
worth is 40 million number four Rachel
Maddow MSNBC and number five Tucker
makes eight million dollars a year it
could have been he might have had an
adjustment in his contract recently as
of 2022 net worth only 30 million
because there's other reports with that
how much is money going to be a factor I
mean if you're going to get Tucker you
got to pay him eight to ten million
dollars a year minimum
what do you think
you what do you think of what how much
he's gonna how much is demand me a
factor for him for him
it's not about how much is money going
to be a factor for him there is money
being a factor there is that's what
you're worth
period okay yeah I don't know if that
makes sense or not look my market value
is XYZ today
and here's what I'm willing to do for
XYZ today I can bring this I can do this
and I can do this and here's what I'd
like this thing to be structured as I'm
willing to do five days a week I'm
willing to do this this this that you
know there's a lot of creative ways
right now on what to uh uh what offer to
make to a guy like Tucker I got two guys
call me texting me asking hey you know
if if we were to structure an offer form
how would you structure it for a guy
like Tucker and uh there's there's
different ways to structure uh but it's
not going to be money for him at this
point because some one guy said oh he's
gonna go to Newsmax okay he's gonna go
to newsmap because it's still you know
right leaning that's that's where he's
going to go next it's going to be news
about oh no no he's going to go to daily
wire because he's going to go there to
team up with Ben Shapiro Candace Owens
Jordan Peterson he's going to go there
no no no he's going to go to rumble you
know those guys are a publicly traded
company two and a half billion dollars
they're going to throw money at them
they'll come out of nowhere and go race
capital and give money at him and he's
going to go to rumble no no he's going
to go do his own thing with Daily Caller
he doesn't need to go to him there's so
many different things that you're
talking about today
Tucker gets to sit down with his wife
and the people he respects
says here's what I want
okay what do you think I should do
well I think you should consider this
and this and this and this okay do you
still want to create shows yes do you
want to go politics I know these other
politics do you want to start a company
I don't want to start a company I like
my life
starting a company as a starting pilot a
stone company is it's a terrible life
when you start a company you don't have
a break you know like hey I'm gonna go
take a two-week PTO good luck starting a
company there's no PTO when you start a
company it's a very different thing does
he want to do that
I I don't know I think I think you know
look at Michael being a player versus an
owner what was he better at playing it's
not even Tucker's a player yes Kenny own
Equity can he have Investments can he
have equity in a deal like a William
Shatner Priceline okay like a you know
Kobe Bryant Water uh what is the vitamin
water or 50 cents yeah so these guys the
equity play is the way to make the money
without having to do the day-to-day
stuff of operating so but there would be
many creative ways Tucker's gotta take
the next if I'm taco right now I'm
taking a week off and I'm telling
everybody I'm good man give me a week
I'm spending time with the wife and I'm
hanging out with the family and I'm
doing my own thing and then sitting
there talking to the 10 people I trust
the most and I'm inviting them over to
my house I'm sitting there talking I'm
saying so what do you think
and and in a way you're going to bring
those people not to ask them what do you
think they're going to be asking you
questions okay and good friends in your
life will ask you questions and they're
going to prompt thought that make
thoughts you didn't have before and then
he's gonna say okay well this is maybe
my next move that I'm thinking about
doing great let's go play ball and Pat
you mentioned about we tell you touched
on about politics what do you think the
a percentage would be because you're
talking about him and I mean I believe
him I know I know I think he loves the
country and he's pro-american I've you
know he's he spits facts left and right
what do you think that the percentage or
the chances are that he goes you know
what I'm gonna I'm gonna take a shift if
you really care and try to change and go
into politics and be like a let's say a
vice president for a president that's
going to be the front runner and then
next time he's not a vice president no
he'd go for a president Tucker is a
president listen if a freaking comedian
in Ukraine becomes a president and it's
painted as Church yeah by the left yeah
this guy can be the president yeah and
by the way Churchill what did he do
before he went into politics what was he
in what industry
was it the car what industry was
Churchill in he was a writer you know he
wrote so many books articles journalism
he was he was in that space a lot of
people from that space this this could
be a a a a way of
shocking everybody next week Tucker
Carlson announces 2024 run yeah what wow
yeah the world will lose their mind if
he says that okay
um
and what about his chances Pat like if
he does let's just say he does and let's
say Trump is the number one and it's him
and and it goes on to him and Trump what
do you think a percentage of the people
that like whatever his chances I think
he's automatically number two wow
oh pbd how can you say that I think he
you guys are so funny
you were so funny when you say how could
you say that listen you know uh uh why
did Trump run for office and win why he
was tired of everything yeah no he has
no background on first of all which one
of those guys he ran with had more
experience in actual policies and
politics than Trump which one on the
stage except for Carson every one of
them yes what are you talking about
Rubio well you know the what was the
guy's name from Walker Massachusetts
what was the guys Scott Walker is going
to be the one that's going to be running
by a winning present Jeb Bush
Generations you know father brother
president Prescott 140 million dollars
they won and then Trump shows up
O'Donnell or whatever he said right
why did he because he gets eyeballs
listen you know who's on fire right now
you know who's on fire right now he's
such a necessary voice today every time
I watch this I'm like this freaking guy
is great at what he's doing Vivek
ramaswani yeah it's unbelievable at what
he's doing right now I don't know
whether he's gonna win or not but the
way he handles debates arguments points
he makes brilliant smart politics
success one immigrant 38 he's got so
many things going for himself and he
knows how to defend yet give his own
argument he's got so many things going
on but even him
Tucker Starts day one he's number two
Tucker Starts day one he's got the
number one show for God knows how many
years the day he starts Tucker's number
two uh again not because of experience
in politics because that's the Santa
sent Trump eyeballs it's because he gets
eyeballs
day one wow okay now by the way can we
run a poll run a poll Rob of do you
think Tucker Carlson would run for
president okay and I'm gonna give mine
I'm gonna write down I want you to see
what the polls are going to be within
them because last time I was I got a
ride it was 61 right I'm gonna write my
score right here yeah the chances of
Tucker Carlson running for president
okay okay all right so just chances of
him running chances of him this time
around chances and I'm talking 2024. I'm
not talking future today rob you start
the poll Tom can you guys all I'll play
it on my phone text text yourself okay
text yourself what you said the ratios
are I'm gonna put mine okay I'm gonna
put mine
and this one is risky of him running
uh this one is risky but I'm gonna write
this down oh man I'm so curious this is
just of him running that's it came
running
okay this is of him running okay oh if I
get it right on the dot all right I'm
gonna put it right there you're guessing
what they're they're I'm gonna guess
what they're gonna guess let's see if
we're connected so the risk we're taking
Folks by the way some people are gonna
totally answer it the other way just to
kind of screw up the algorithms but it
is what it is we'll play along so
Tom likelihood of Tucker running 2024.
my number yes
what was it 30. you're at 30 what are
you doing 25 what did you put
he's probably like five percent
seriously eighty percent he's running
yeah you just sold
here I am non-believer now I'm 80 DVD
salesman market right here okay
we have 2 300 votes in the first minute
let's see what we got what is it what
does it say I said 20. oh my God I'm
good what did it say 26 75 25 look at my
answer I put 28 yes 72 percent they said
75 25. we're on the same page how insane
is that huh you know your audience I
don't think they think he's gonna run
because there's a high likelihood he
doesn't run okay there's no saying I'm
the biggest Tucker
what I'm saying to you is if he does
he's number two day one damn I'm telling
you watch this think about this you
watch the question I'm about to ask you
listen to the question I'm about to ask
you ready yeah here's a question I'm
about to ask you
put Trump put the santis put Tucker okay
who has made the most money in his
lifetime Donald Trump okay who has the
most experience coming up military
conference Governor State not even close
the perfect recipe you ready who has
debated the most on National Television
a creepy porn lawyer one of my favorites
I think this guy's got it I think he's a
guy that can actually do it I just I
just don't know because here's what's
going to happen you know uh uh uh you
you can learn a lot about a lot of
different people on how they live their
lives this this is a guy that based on
what I'm hearing he does a show from his
house he's not a guy that's traveling
all the time to DC to other places he's
not a guy that wants that harassment
that's coming his way all the time he
wants to live a a different kind of a
life he's not Trump that he wants to be
out there there's a part of the
scientist that DeSantis also doesn't
want to be out there but the Santas
loves America of course and DeSantis is
a fighter and since he was 18 years all
the centers wanted to be a president
okay that's come when I'm convinced that
DeSantis was the guy that in high school
you're like this guy wants to be a
president he's going to be somebody
someday he's not a guy that accidentally
became a congressman accidentally became
a governor this is a guy that knew
intentionally he was going to be that
and by the way respect and salute to
anybody that had a vision and that
Vision became a reality 100 but if
Tucker's right now sitting around
thinking what I do next boom
here we go but breaking news nah Tucker
Carlson and Don Lemon team up a new show
on MSNBC called mother Tucker and there
it is
you can totally see it totally joking
good actor yeah that's a red pill
blueprint yeah that would be a funny
thing no but but again so with Tucker
It's so funny at the beginning we told
the Don Lemon story and not once have we
touched on the Don Lemon I will say why
why what do you actually think is the
future for someone like Don Lemon at
this point you want me to tell you yeah
you ready for this answer yeah it's Tom
you're gonna like this answer Don
lemon's future is to go to any network
that needs a great Dei score 100
you're right you're right yes or no
you're right that lemon is going to go
to any network that needs to improve
their deities
that's right he's a he's a Dei score
candidate what are the what's the
likelihood that Don ends up on Fox and
he's like the old Juan Williams one
black guy Democrat just getting
lambasted uh by the rest of the the team
over there on the five I don't see Don
Lemon as a hard-working guy who research
stories books I don't see him as that
guy
you're just far without doing your work
first of all he's it's very hard to look
that good he's a very good looking guy
good talker you know extremely confident
in himself very confident in himself he
is a guy that's like he just he he looks
at himself as a uh what do you call it
as a superstar but there's a ward for it
he looks at himself as a
um I'm somebody he thinks iliums of
himself he's got a very Larger than Life
confidence in himself that's Don Lemon
no but Don Lemon is not I don't see Don
Lemon being Chris Cuomo I think Chris
Cuomo was Chris Cuomo he was a
heavyweight I think Kris Cuomo studied I
think Chris Cuomo called his brother I
think Chris Cuomo stayed up reading
articles I think Chris Cuomo got up
early to work out and read every article
and saw everything that everybody said
on Twitter the day before I see him
doing that I saw Chris Cuomo doing that
I even think madal does that I think
Morning Joe does that I don't think he
does that but a little bit lazier and I
don't think Don's gonna find a network
like CNN that I mean for all that time
watches your ass and mind you know how
Sassy he'd be on air somebody would say
something he's like listen oh you can
walk out I'll cut you off the air right
now he's not gonna find a place like hey
guys any final thoughts because before
we wrap up I gotta head up to us gang if
you're watching this and we were on the
same page with the score give us a sub
to the channel here we got 26 000 live
watches you love these shoes that you
gave me because they don't fit you what
are these called those are the Christian
uh uh Louis Vuitton Louboutin red
bottoms I've never so by the way those
are my dad's red bottoms that he'll
never wear because his feet are wide
look at you realize and it's raining
outside I'm never gonna wear these those
those looks I don't know you don't want
to wear those outside
I think this is great so
I love to see the comments I want to I'm
gonna go back and read all the comments
for this because I believe our audience
has got some so from the from the new
home of New Media I'd love them to let
us know what they think is going on I
want to see the comments I want to see
the audience win disruption disrupts and
disruption mainstream media's dying
podcasting is growing and give us a sub
y'all hey gang I think we got a Celeste
I gotta drive up to Boca right now yes
we got SLS yeah we're gonna be together
two days and then we got a live Podcast
Thursday I think uh we're together it's
gonna be an interesting one and we're
back at it again next week take care
everybody have a great day bye-bye bye
bye